every night it's the same
it's the show that put northern ireland
on the map my dreams are different
mine are true what did you see
something bad
and cast at the opening of the game of
thrones studio tour felt they'd come
home when i um when i got in last night
i kind of nearly cried i felt very
nostalgic like landing into belfast and
coming out the airport oh my god
it was just such a big part of my life
you know coming here and working on the
show it was it was a it was a nice thing
to be a part of you know to have so many
people around the world
fanatical about
the show and supporting your every move
is is
a rarity you don't often get that on tv
shows this 40 million pound visitor
attraction in county down is a huge
boost for tourism as it seeks a route
back from covid
the iron throne has produced gold for
the northern ireland economy game of
thrones accounting for a staggering
quarter of a billion pounds and one in
six tourists before the pandemic hbo
coming to the province has been one of
the greatest things ever to happen to
this province they spent some 250
million pounds on this show over eight
seasons uh in 2018 there were over 300
000 tourists came into the province
spending 50 million pounds uh so it's a
gift it keeps on giving and when this
pandemic finally ends this is going to
be such an incredible attraction for the
fans we've got a prime minister
currently engaged in his own game of
thrones how do you think he would do in
his battle for the political kingdom i'd
said the dragons would get him pretty
quickly
[Laughter]
back in this fictional world they're
hopeful winter isn't coming but that the
tourists are david blevins sky news
inbound bridge